devant expédié sur dix trouvent sur
dungeon nightmare sto le jeu final est
sorti on avait fait une vidéo sur le 1
et sur la bêta du 2 mars super vite
ces chiens on arrive dans le donjon des
cauchemars aux alors troubles autres et
débatteur pourtant fuir [ __ ] ça veut
dire un truc je me souviens bien tout ça
bordel on voit rien ouah voilà il ya des
coffres bon alors nous ça comme ça et
des fois de donner des bougies comme ça
on peut allumer des bougies
voilà et là on voit beaucoup mieux à
chaque voilier map
effectivement et on doit trouver des
notes et la [ __ ] de sortie il ya du
sang lavage plein de sang partout alors
est ce que vous arrivez dans la pièce
avec des squelettes celle où je sais que
ça a pas tardé
ne prenez pas pour un imbécile a passé
l'escalier de ses deux sorties déjà avec
steve carell rapide quoi hockey devait
en fait c'est un mec chaque nuit fais
des cauchemars et connaît dans le donjon
c'est son cauchemar en fait de trouver
la sortie cd terreurs nocturnes la sapn
qu'elle rêve étrange qu'est ce qu'il
veut dire
eh ben on va dans le bon couloir de la
mort yahoo un psychopathe nous attend or
comment ce truc ne bougeait sol mais je
suis une excellente qualité au retour
dans ton lit 306 je donne clé se donne
une clé ou qu'elle est c'est là toute
les nus qu'on va devoir passer dans ce
[ __ ] de donjons à trouver des clés
pour 8 août c'est non mais tout est
fermé mec
ok c'est reparti mon âge peut pas aller
dans le conduit non non si aller laisse
moi mon âme est ok vin relancer le jeu
en fait il y avait juste un bogue où là
ça m'a lâché plus j'étais bloqué c'est
génial n'est pas un passage là mais
ouais mec mais oh oh oh la vache on
n'est pas un coffre au [ __ ] mais
qu'est ce que tu sais que ça allait à
quoi là dedans des bougies masse bougies
une note plus ta mère est fait mettre
les menottes à l'envers veille on dirait
que certains d'entre eux n'aiment pas la
lumière
oui cela n'est pas étonnant est le mieux
c'est de casser ce n'est de se barrer
hockey en a aucun c'est bon on est bon
on est bon en fait dès que je mets un
petit coup de lumière par qui se
rapproche à ce casse pas voilà on cercle
et j'ai pas bien chaud qu'à ce plan
biplan by droite et souhaiterait pas un
petit coup de chaud il y avait un putsch
ok ok on est en hausse des taux en
direct vous étant dit apte à je suis
hypersensible aux scream aujourd'hui à
des jours comme ça où tu es très
sensible they do des émotions hashtag
fragilité j'étais en vie je répète à
rigautou une vision ok go away from your
ya rien
y'a rien je tourne en rond je tourne en
rond sur son nom reste attaché plus la
suite y'a pas mieux répéter c'est très
fort c'est murat pt du coup je rase les
murs il ya des bruits choix je souhaite
qu'ils oublient bouge il est
éventuellement attirés par notre notre
corps n'ont versé que cette photo il
espère c'est el oula oula attends
attends quand tu dit elle on est bien
d'accord ok ok l'espace trop de trucs à
la fois calme et vous monsieur le géant
kit qui tape qui est fâché quand il
quand il dit est ce que c'était les
parts de qui on est dans l
il parle d'une petite fille mignonne pas
dans un esprit salesse nommé par un
président qui veut couper la gorge ça
gratte la barbe à la barbichette me
tiens je te atari go l'est rien ni
personne pour amant mur qui se créent au
c'est quoi ça j'ai la gauche j'suis pas
de moi j'irai droit pour rien mais ça
des états qui a des gauches [ __ ] olala
et ex aequo john recouverte de sang
maintenant room 313 ch à la clé la route
313 un truc faut remonter à la surface
en mourir bah le monde soit sangloter on
va l'attendre va tourner autour du pot
tomoya retrouve la sortie trouve la
sortie trouve la sauter sans père
coupait si elle va venir là on va passer
à côté du poteau l'a pas nous toucher au
départ vous allez voir ça s'approche et
la fumée elle est là elle a plein la vue
et wes père de conan soit a pas beaucoup
joué à l'épervier est à toi tout droit à
la faillite ou droit ok la sortie elle
est là je sens on peut la sentir
il n'a pas de power mais non mais faut
trouver le put un générateur pour
allumer bon le pire c'est que j'ai fait
toute la map
ça veut dire qu'il ya un endroit où il
ya générateur et j'ai pas fait gaffe
voilà et moi avons l'instant la
chercheure à nevers
la boum elle en a aussi de chalenge on
se tenir d'ici à plus à le monde pourri
et souterrains pourquoi je suis encore
là je n'en sais rien 313 babe olava shot
fuck où on la voit je pense que la porte
est bloqué mais sur un coeur des tirs
vite suppute 1 et bien retourner
l'ascenseur on va faire la deuxième nuit
au la brh mais ça c'est un petit joker
interdit par la loi française ça alors
là ça c'est interdit lui de trouver une
autre clé et une sortie au les murs ont
changé oh [ __ ] j'ai thomas bouchet
direct regarder
il était près du but et quoi faudrait
que je fasse venir ici genre là
maintenant c'est ça sa irai [ __ ] t'es
figurants dont le retour de la momie et
tu te sens plus arrête
allô allô cela est un bug
cela est à m'essayer à coude parce qu'en
ce moment actuel est vrai que j'ai là
non c'est une blague
[ __ ] ça n'est pas sauvegardé j'en peux
plus en ce moment je suis beauty tous
les jeux bug ça va pas sauvegarder la
gamme d'avant je dois retenue chercher
la clé mais alors vous savez quoi
maintenant je me laisse plus faire
parler jeu on va sur un autre jeu
d'horreur plus tard voilà huit euros 99
dans le cul on apprend que celui du
dessus bienvenue sur stranger's un jeu à
deux euros 99 qui est peut-être vraiment
bien j'ai pris ma voiture et suis allé
dans la maison de campagne
oh je me sens bien d'un coup loin de ce
[ __ ] de donjons buggé je me sens grave
vient d'être dit street il ya des
voleurs ils ont cambriolé la maison de
peter james fait attention robe ok je
suis heureux d'être jugé comme ça parce
qu'on voit ça bug pas tout voir je vais
envoyer c'est très bien à ce moment
précis je cuisine n'a encore aucune idée
de ce qui l'attend regardez bien cette
tête de course
je devrai mettre mes vêtements là ok c
ou là que j'aurais fait des [ __ ] de
vêtements il a dit que je devais est
nettement la hausse est pas là non mais
s'il vous plaît la non mais je suis
maudit aujourd'hui la malédiction de la
vidéo aucun piquet [ __ ] de rallier au
plafond que la dernière fois et c'est
parfait mais je me devais table
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas moins de 6000
monde y mette mes vêtements l' odorat
celle en contre s'il vous plaît faites
n'ont rien eu marre je quitte ce jeu de
merde on va faire le test le test de la
malédiction au pendjab hertault de si je
la perds c'est koné maudits jusqu'au
bout ces matches là sa vidéo s emballer
style mais je te voir si les mots dits
de jeux de suite de problèmes ça va au
jade ce métier je démissionne
un luthier il n'a pas colère qui fait -3
aucune et c'est pas mon jour même sur
aguerris ont regardé en moins de 10 de
10 secondes va se faire manger je le
sens bien d aller pour le ostia la
malédiction elles marchent pas soit
gharios au regard des eaux la chance
lachor cette masse est apparu c'est un
cadeau c'est un cadeau du youtube il se
passe un truc à la détection est parti
doit faire tout les mecs et à l'essai
raté
[ __ ] merci tu doutes hume nous protège
aulas andré attention devant toi oh là
là là là là là on est plus élevé du
monde inquiet mais je ne viens pas de
cette vidéo absolument na waïe qui voilà
j'espère quand même que ça vous a plu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la
vidéo et à me dire quoi faire pour ne
plus être maudit voilà je vous avais des
petits rites vaudou ou des incantations
à faire pour quelle malédiction sans aie
aie aie sur un youtube heures basit mois
voilà j'ai serré on verra si tout eu
peur des problèmes de leur prochaine
vidéo mais ça le regarde et au centre
très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
art et vous me adjé tout le monde pis